hi las vegas now
who doesn't love a red carpet event and
i have you covered for all your viewing
parties movie nights and premieres with
one of my favorite snacks
oppo pop this is america's favorite new
gourmet popcorn on a mission to liberate
you from that plain boring popcorn their
flavor wrapped popcorn kernels come in
six signature flavors including
reimagined classics such as fancy butter
and uniquely created experiences like
maui heat and vanilla cake pop
they also just launched a new product
for snack size snacking peel and pour
popcorn cups i am loving the salty
caramel
check out opop.com online to find the
right party pack for your celebration
looking for the perfect ready to drink
option for your viewing party luxardo
can cocktails has you covered they are
the newest addition to luxardo's
portfolio and are crafted with premium
spirits and liqueurs luxardo's apertivo
spritz and bianco spritz bring a premium
flavor of a traditional spritz in the
convenience of a can making it easier
than ever to enjoy hassle-free cocktails
at home or while out mixing and mingling
not a fan of bubbles go to
luxardocancocktails.com and check out
luxardo's sour cherry gin and tonic
canned cocktails cheers
now did you know that your brows frame
75 of your face and i have the perfect
duo for you to try for your red carpet
premiere from kim roxy who created
lameek beauty's revelation brow duo this
is so easy to apply great for beginners
and it's the perfect combination of brow
powder and cream to sculpt define and
color those brows i have it on now the
cruelty-free formula contains clean
non-toxic ingredients such as jojoba oil
to give you a naturally fuller look with
a weightless feel pigmented application
and satin finish you can choose from
over 15 combinations for your perfect
shade match and great for all diverse
skin tones go to lameekbeauty.com
lastly bluestone sunshields is the
number one doctor recommended brand of
sunshield it was founded by licensed
esthetician jen podney when she saw a
need for a product that would provide
privacy and sun protection for her
patients and clients who had just
undergone some special treatments or
just wanted to escape the flashes of the
paparazzi
bluestone is founded on the mission to
provide the best and most fashionable
protection i am personally loving the
new zadie shades
each comes with three interchangeable
lenses in rainbow black and chrome it's
like getting three shades in one and our
unisex
need to protect against the elements you
know those hot days and nights in vegas
the blue stone sun scarf is the perfect
carry-along accessory it's made with
advanced cooling and uv blocking
technology fabric and the perfect
addition to any bikini or outfit
go to
bluestonessunshields.com to order yours
today happy award season vegas i'll see
you next month to celebrate products
founded created or developed by women